what's up guys
lunch money time while wall street's
trying to get rich the rest of us just
trying to get much money right
i am here well technically not there
with the lovely and beautiful miss
polina marinova
uh so we are doing this remote today uh
what's going on in the world i see that
you've got a beautiful
sheep wool vest on today yeah it's
chilly
um so you were
us weekly jobless claims total 3.1
million dollars
that means that 33.5 million people are
out of work
3.1 million or 3.1 million people
did i say dollars people yeah
so 3.1 million people unemployed in the
last week
which puts the total to 33.5 million in
the last seven weeks
uh this is going to continue until we
get people back to work
right i mean we're kind of beating a
dead horse every week with this
but the government has mandated the
shutdown of the u.s economy
and i don't think that people are going
to go back to work until they can get
out of quarantine
so it's uh it's pretty sad but um
i i don't know any new thoughts uh from
last week when there was
30 million people that it was
interesting
that florida was the most responsible
for the big dip
i don't know why florida
yeah it's a good question and i mean
part of it too is
uh i wonder how these numbers are going
to change as they begin reopening the
economies right so we saw a couple of
states
start to reopen florida um reopen some
of the beaches and things like that
uh i i do wonder will we get um
the um kind of you know recurring
unemployment claims to go down a little
bit because people are actually going
back to work or not
i don't know we'll see but uh but but
this number is just
frankly it's just depressing right i
mean 33 million americans is more than
uh 20 of the uh the um united states
workforce
right and that's the official number so
i don't know
it's wiped out all the job gains the
economy has seen since the recovery from
the great recession so that tells you
everything you need to know
all right what's going on with sam zell
mr sam zell
am i being too subtle a fantastic book
highly recommend going to read
yeah you really like that book
it's funny sam's
he said we're all going to be
permanently scarred and he cautions that
the coronavirus will leave a great
depression level dent
in the economy
yeah i mean it's possible definitely
psychologically i think it's going to uh
change the way that people view a lot of
activities right i mean you and i have
talked about like
do you go to a movie theater after this
how do you feel about getting in the
subway right in a packed car
so psychologically i think that there'll
be social change
i'm assuming he's talking more about
kind of the way that people think about
investing as well
right and do they change the way that
they um you know they allocate capital
i don't know what do you think that
people will actually change that
materially
how they allocate capital yeah
probably i i thought it was interesting
what he said about uh real estate
because that's
kind of what he specializes in he said
that a wave of bankruptcies is necessary
for economic recovery
but the pro the viruses uh pressure on
demand will drive more deep
yeah i mean look sam zell is actually
one of these people who uh he believes
in uh
in free markets right and the idea that
the defaults and the bankruptcies what
they'll actually do is they clean out
the bad company
right those companies who have been bad
capital allocators uh or aren't
performing
um you have two options either you let
them fail which is a natural market
occurrence or you can go in and save
them you can interfere
right uh i think we're doing a little
too much interfering and trying to save
people
like they made bad decisions they took a
risk they lost
let them fail and somebody else will
come in and buy those properties hire
those employees
and they'll be much better capital
allocators um you know moving forward
we haven't talked too much about like
the the state of the real estate
market what's going on there do you know
well there's two things that are really
interesting so one
residential real estate uh home prices
are actually going up
right they're not going down and you
would expect i think just on the onset
hey there's a liquidity crisis people
are panic selling
uh house prices should go down but
they've actually been going up i think
they ticked up eight percent recently
um and the reason is uh there's been a
shortage
um or supply shock at the same time that
there's demand shock
and so i think that that's been a little
counter-intuitive and surprised people
on the residential side on the
commercial side
and this is really what sam became
famous for he built the largest
commercial real estate reit sold for
about 40 billion dollars
to blackstone the commercial market is
going to
change drastically i don't know if we're
seeing that yet
but there's a lot of talk of companies
either changing the way they think about
their floor plans
so rather than have kind of these open
floor plans going back to
having cubicles and everyone has their
own office and things that are less open
uh because of the virus or just saying
look we're actually going to optimize
for
remote work right or or smaller offices
and so kind of the class a real estate
uh the commercial space ends up becoming
less desirable
and so naturally you know prices kind of
come down over time
question is when will that happen and
two how long does that take
and people in new york are demanding a
rent freeze so we'll see what happens
uh peloton it had do you think
wait hold on a second this is hard doing
this remote we're
we're champs for doing this uh do you
think that people should get the rent
freeze
think if you show you have some sort of
hardship or you've lost your job for x
period of time or
i don't know it's really tough
especially in new york
yeah well it's uh it's one of these
things where
you go back to if you freeze rent
all you're doing is you're transferring
uh the risk
and the pain for somebody else right so
you're taking it from the renter
putting it on the landlord if you then
do something at the landlord level then
you're transferring that risk and paying
to
uh the lender um you know for the
mortgage or whoever and so you can't
really
alleviate the pain all you do is you try
to offload it to somebody
else uh and then that just comes down to
a question of like
is that fair right or is there
um you know breaking a social contract
but think about it if you and i both
lost our jobs um
and didn't have work at the time could
we afford to live here
in new york city
no of course not but that but that's
kind of the whole situation
right is again i go back to and this is
highly sensitive right so i kind of
caveat with i
understand why people don't like when i
say this but
i don't know anyone who is um
significantly struggling
right now who has multiple streams of
income
and who spends consistently less than
they make
so it's one of these things where if
people did
the hard disciplined unpopular things in
the good times
they're actually set up very very good
right now right in many cases they
they've got savings they've got multiple
streams of income etc
right so you're saying diversify your uh
revenue stream
yeah yeah it's just it's just the whole
idea of like those people are doing
well or at least not suffering that much
people who are not in that position
right that they're in um there's a lot
of pain and and that doesn't discount
that pain like that pain is really bad
and we should
do everything we can but part of this is
you know
there's short-term pain which is uh
being able to pay your rent or not
uh and then there's medium to long-term
um kind of solutions right so we've got
to do a better job of educating people
financially
we got to do a better job of providing
people tools so they can go build
companies or get additional revenue
streams um you know and also helping
people stay disciplined and saving and
changing the way consumers think about
spending
but that stuff doesn't solve the
short-term problem and also doesn't
happen overnight
so i think this just highlights uh you
know we got a lot of work to do coming
out of this it's just as much as
trying to help people right now
awesome peloton the fitness company that
makes the bike and the treadmill had one
of its
best if not the best quarters ever
um it bested wall street estimates
um for the quarter brought in 524.6
million dollars
uh estimates were 488 million and
they're growing really fast
what do you think
i'm not surprised are you
no everybody we know got a peloton
except for us we don't need a peloton
yeah we work out on the on the floor
huh do you want to tell do you want to
tell them what uh what we've been doing
lately for a workout
yup do you want me to tell them what
we've been doing lately for a workout
sure i told my brothers recently and
they thought it was cool
um there's there's an app that
kayla it cena's i think i think that's
how you pronounce her name
has called sweat and it has exercises
that you can do
um from anywhere without you know
gym equipment and it's really good and
we've been doing it
and you're sore it's like high-intensity
uh
interval training basically right it's
like seven minutes
of uh four exercises and you go through
those four exercises as many times as
you can in the seven minutes
and then it's like okay done and like oh
just kidding another seven minutes
you end up doing it four times and by
the time you get to the fourth one
you're like yo
i hate this lady this lady is so mean
why is she making us do this but then
you get done and you're like hey this is
pretty good workout
but you know why i don't want to get a
peloton
why i cannot justify
in my mind spending 2 245
for a bike or 4 000 for a treadmill
i can run outside
yeah that's true i don't disagree with
you
no not at the moment
i i don't want to uh i don't want to
digress here
but uh or uh go off on a tangent but
biking is super weird as a workout
like you're just sitting there and
moving your legs
but like i don't know i just never
thought of that as a workout
yeah i always thought of that as like a
leisure activity not really a workout
activity but
it's hard i guess so i don't know um all
right what's going on papa john's
papa papa john's the question is
what's going to happen to companies like
peloton after the pandemic's over
because obviously this
cannot go on forever so what are they
going to do when
people aren't you know stuck inside for
a long period of time
okay ironically papa john's had its
best month ever um in the company's
history
so does this mean that people are
working out on their peloton and then
just grabbing pizza
i think that's exactly what that means
but everyone knows domino's
is better than papa john's first of all
second of all
uh i wonder how much of the business
is coming through delivery apps versus
directly
through uh the papa john's website and
the reason why i asked that
is domino's stock price it's no secret
it has been on absolute tear for the
last like five or six years
uh a lot of that was because they nailed
online delivery and mobile ordering and
so they just
very quickly realize like hey for us to
win in this world we have to be a
technology company
and domino's did a really good job there
i believe that
papa john's recently has learned from
that and started to try to catch up
and so it looks like they probably
building that up and now that we get the
quarantine ban everyone's ordering mine
and then it sounds like a tank off
um it says that they have one million
new customers coming into the franchise
and a lot of those are coming through
their loyalty program i'm not familiar
with their loyalty program but i'm
guessing it's
kind of what you said maybe there's an
app maybe they can order
uh without having to call or go online
yeah i think the loyalty program is
super interesting and it also brings
into mind like
it's basically a new version of
subscription right so what you're
starting to see is all these uh food
companies
uh historically we're very low tech
they're learning from a lot of the
technology companies they're making
investments in
r d they're making investments in
technology they're changing their
business models or evolving the business
models
and it's paying off right they're
driving sales and and obviously stock
price benefits from it
so uh you and i aren't ordering any papa
john's maybe we should try it out but uh
i'll stick with domino's and some cheesy
bread and uh you know a little
uh large pepperoni pizza i know you love
dominoes don't try to hide it either
yeah we've been ordering dominoes i
don't even know if there's is there a
papa john's in new york
city probably probably
i haven't seen all right what's going on
man
so okay so new york is interesting
uh there was a protest recently about a
dozen people
who were socially distancing doing
everything wearing the masks etc
except their video came out where a new
york police official
said this gathering is unlawful and you
are ordered to disperse
gatherings of any kind have been
prohibited by the governor and by the
mayor
and then de blasio who's the mayor
basically came out and just
outwardly said protests are illegal you
cannot do this
you want to know what i think about this
sure i think that de blasio's a clown
for saying that this goes right to the
heart
of our constitutional rights we have
the freedom of assembly and
we have the first amendment we can say
what we want
and we can gather when we want that is
what america
is about i don't give a [ __ ]
what bill de blasio says if they are
going to protest
bank uh if they're going to have bans on
protest
they are breaking the law to clarify
no said people who want to make their
voices heard there are plenty of ways to
do it without gathering in person
so he's saying technically you can still
protest but you can't be in person
well it would be great here's the thing
is the government
doesn't get to choose how the people
protest this is the problem that the
government has right now
they are forgetting bill de blasio works
for us
we don't bill de blasio doesn't own us
bill de blasio doesn't get to tell us
what to do
bill de blasio works for us and
therefore
bill de blasio doesn't get to tell us
when and where we can protest or when
and where we can say stuff
that is what communist ism is that is
not what the american constitution
represents
and therefore this is just classic
bureaucratic garbage
yeah so basically uh and this kind of
all sparked because there was a group of
um uh lgbt there was a lgbtq
group protesting a religious uh
group and uh after the police broke up
the demonstration
people were saying how they're concerned
that these social distancing safety
orders
are being used to curtail free speech
which
i kind of agree with too
well and here's the thing it wasn't a de
blasio who tweeted out
uh saying something like uh to all to
the jewish community like we're not
going to let you
uh gather right and it's i mean it's
history it's literally targeting a
religious group
right and saying you can't do that that
this is again you can't allow these
crisis
to uh allow the government to impede on
your personal freedoms or civil
liberties
and this is a perfect example where the
government believes the constitution
only applies
when it is helpful to them but what they
don't realize is the constitution is
written
to protect the people from an
overreaching government
this is an overreach you can't tell
people right
i think people as long as they're
gathering in a safe manner and they're
keeping social distance they have their
masks on why not let them protest
uh but i think the government would say
oh we're just doing this because we're
trying to save lives
if they were trying to save lives then
what they should do
is one they should stop lying about the
data and two they should get testing
stop what the reason why people are
protesting is because people are
suffering
they're not out there protesting for fun
they don't want to be out there
protesting they want to be back at work
they want to make sure that they live in
a safe healthy
in community right their protest they're
literally protesting the government
because they don't agree with what the
government is doing it's not a it's not
like they're you know
getting uh it's not a game and so i just
think that like it just doesn't make
sense
to me why they're saying this
and it i think further highlights um you
know you or
maybe you talk a little bit about just
like how you think about free speech in
these situations and then trying to stop
it
uh i'm all about free speech i don't
think a protest would be as effective on
zoom
um but yeah i mean
what are you gonna protest
i'm a protest uh you wearing that sheep
thing when i'm not there i feel like
that thing's fluffy like i could just
rub it
i love it very fluffy and it's very soft
um okay what you want to say
okay so it's interesting because i've
read reports where dating is actually
or people are uh online dating more than
they were before the pandemic except now
tinder um is saying that there's a
slowing user growth so they're not
getting as many
people on the app i'm not sure if the
activity is increasing but anyway
so they're saying they're gonna add
video dating next quarter
uh to kind of boost the user growth
good idea or bad idea i mean it's
interesting like why would i don't need
tinder
to zoom with someone right like you
would think that
what are you doing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but anyway i feel like the point of
tinder is i know
brother single any girl my youngest
brother's single
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right uh so wait do you think that
the video is a bad idea
so i think that the point of tinder and
all these other apps is just to meet
people right
why do i need to video chat with someone
on tinder where i can just get their
like
zoom id and and if i hit it off with
them i can just zoom with them
what's the point well it's probably just
that it's more seamless
right so like the whole idea of uh if
you and i were on dating apps
and we matched then right there in the
same app we
can uh we can video with each other
rather than have to get the
zoom id or move over to something else
i guess that's true but do you think
that's enough to attract new users to
the app
no it's probably actually a retention
tool right so it's less about getting
new users to come in
and it's more about keeping the users
that you have so that they spend more
time in the app
that you can monetize them better uh and
you get and you keep
uh better retention rates what would
your opening line be if you match with
me on tinder
oh no
[Laughter]
that's pretty cool that's pretty good i
probably would hit you with a
i must ask you a question oh god
you don't even have a mustache it's all
right i'd grow one
all right what else anything else you
can work for the people
i'm sorry guys that this sucks that uh
remote is a little uh
a little harder than in person but uh i
think we're doing a pretty good job so
deal with it yeah well just get your
lunch money right and be kind to your
friends
your money get paid get money get paid
also this is proof that virtual dating
would be really hard because look
somebody's going to lag
the other person is going to freeze
somebody's brothers are going to come in
like it's hard yeah
i probably look better in person than i
do on video you know it's all right
[Laughter]
all right guys listen we appreciate you
watching today uh while she's trying to
get rich the rest of us trying to get
our lunch money right
uh we will uh see you guys tomorrow one
more day remote
and then we will be back monday together
with all of our laughs and magic so
we will see you later